foreign
[Music]
we're kind of a below the radar race to
be perfectly honest thank you all for
being here I know as Chad said we are in
the dog days of summer and I know there
are many places you could be I got into
the race to protect the American dream
um I'm a product of that my grandmother
immigrated here from Mexico as a young
girl and so I believe in the power of
that I put myself through college at ASU
go devils
I think I'm very much the person I am
today because of how I grew up I was so
lucky to be raised by real salt of the
earth people my nana immigrated here
from Mexico when she was a young girl my
great-grandparents were migrant Farm
Workers and like so many they looked to
the United States for their chance at a
better life being from a family of
immigrants being in a great country of
immigrants I am pro-legal immigration
but we also know that there are bad guys
out there that want to bring drugs into
the country or that are trafficking
women or children or that want to do
harm to our country and so we need to
make sure that we are doing everything
we can to keep those folks out and
welcome in the ones like my grandparents
who are looking to build a better life
the diversity of this community as
distinct as of the Bronx as beautiful as
the blossoms of Miami
I believe the Democratic party
absolutely takes Latino support for
granted and I think they've done that
for a long time what I couldn't believe
is that that was actually a scripted
moment right like people say things off
the cuff and think oh man what a
bonehead thing but that had been
scripted
um I think it's really unfortunate
because obviously Latinos
um we're so much so much more than that
and um I think you know things like that
also show where the Democrat Party is
losing the support of the Latino
Community because
we're put into this box I think this is
going to be a huge wake-up call for them
in November if it hasn't been already
that they're not going to No One Latino
or otherwise is just going to vote with
a party because it's owed to the party
we have to fight every day to earn the
support and votes of our constituents I
think the values uh that certainly were
in my family growing up and I think with
many Latino families of Faith and family
and freedom and Entrepreneurship which
is huge in the Latino Community those
are things that really resonate with me
and I think are in alignment with the
Republican party this is obviously my
Charles Barkley bobblehead who is one of
the greatest sons of all times I've been
blessed to have incredible experiences I
would say those are going to make me
even better in Congress because what
I've learned through those various
experiences how to bring people together
probably the most fun thing I've done
professionally was working for the
Phoenix Suns as an executive as a kid
growing up I watched the sons at the
madhouse on McDowell and so to then be
part of that storied franchise and count
some of the old Legends as my my
co-workers was really a lot of fun but
more importantly I want to hear from all
of you I'm the only one in the primary
that can beat Greg Stanton and that's
what this is really all about at the end
of the day day we want to flip this seat
in November and I'm the candidate that
can do it from a policy standpoint there
are some pretty significant differences
between myself and the incumbent I want
secure borders I want less spending I
want to always have the backs of our law
enforcement these are things that he has
not been a leader on in Congress and I
will be that's what I'm going to be
talking to the voters about and I think
what they're going to find is that they
don't feel like things are going great
and they're going to be ready for a
change and I look forward to delivering
that
foreign